[Music]
he mentioned a windowless office
malloc must be using this space
wait you've been here before a few days
ago
1931.
he redecorated
whoa high tech
must be his new base of operations
hydra won't be needing this will they
that's a good thing it were computers in
no firewalls i have no idea what that
means
what are you looking for list of targets
for inside
these are mostly shield assets wait
bruce banner never heard of him
that's because he's just a kid now but
in a few decades he becomes an avenger
is that a good thing or a bad thing it's
a good thing
so they'll do a bad thing pick him up
while he's still young
exactly none of you could survive
how do we know you will we don't
but the radiation's mostly gamma
it's like
i was made for this welcome back
everyone it's charlie this is going to
be my new avengers easter egg video
there was a whole bunch of
hulk easter eggs for incredible hulk
captain america winter soldier and just
general avengers stuff going on during
agents of shield recently
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we'll do a new amazon
giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite hulk
moment
on the video so we'll just number these
as we go along just to stay
organized but the big deal here is is
what's going on in agents of shield
during season seven the final season
is that they're jumping through the
timeline like they did during avengers
end game
but they're going through different
decades in each episode so in this
episode where they were doing all this
incredible hulk stuff they were in the
70s
so most of the episode itself was meant
to be a parody
of the actual original incredible hulk
tv series in addition to doing a bunch
of modern day mcu
incredible hulk bruce banner stuff they
even did a parody of the intro titles
from the incredible hulk tv series and
they played the theme music
during the episode too for a way to tap
into the hidden strengths that all
humans have
then an accidental overdose of gamma
[Music]
radiation
marvel's agents of shield
[Music]
if you're a really big hulk fan the cool
thing that mark ruffalo is actually
working on behind the scenes is he's
trying to get them to do
a new incredible hulk series with his
version of the hulk
no idea when that would happen but he
just said that he's pitching it to be
sort of a revival of the original
incredible hulk tv series with a similar
plot
him on the run thunderbolt ross red hulk
the thunderbolts chasing him down
episode to episode but elsewhere in the
marvel universe
agents of shield this season is kind of
doing the same thing that the loki tv
series is going to be doing
the loki from avengers end game that
escaped with a tesseract
the plot of that series is remarkably
similar to what's going to be happening
during agents of shield season 7 with
them jumping around
altering major events in mcu history the
big difference between what's going on
on agents of shield
and the loki tv series is that loki is
associated with the time variance
authority they're kind of like the time
cops of the marvel cinematic universe or
the time lords if you want to make a
doctor who reference because there's a
lot of doctor who stuff going into the
series
the big difference with agents of shield
is that the villains are the cronomicons
it's the shield agents who are acting
like the time cops
trying to stop them from altering major
events in mcu history
so during this big incredible hulk
episode they're basically trying to jump
star
project insight from captain america
winter soldier remember when they were
targeting people that were going to be
special or special people
themselves there was a giant list of
people that they flash on screen
bruce banner just happened to be one of
the biggest avengers on that list there
were a bunch of other references too
like one of the other people on their
hit list that they had targeted with
project insight during the episode was
nick fury
who at this time as of the events of the
episode in the 70s was still in his 20s
on
active military duty they referenced
peggy carter as a target who was still
active and shield at this time
you have to picture this alternate
reality with the version of steve rogers
just
hiding on the dl captain america growing
old with her slowly
just trying to stay out of the public
limelight the russos did tease that at
some point they might tell that story of
captain america returning the infinity
stones and then going back to live with
peggy carter there's just a really big
time jump between him leaving the
platform here with all the infinity
stones going back to the different time
periods that they stole them from
but also taking back thor's hammer back
to the events of thor of the dark world
for those of you that wonder what
happened to that extra thor's hammer
chris evans teased that he doesn't want
to come back right away but
it's implied that he'll come back to do
the voice overroll for his marvel what
if captain america first avenger episode
because hayley atwell revealed that
peggy carter herself
isn't going gonna show up during agents
of shield season seven they have
susa from the asian carter series so if
you don't remember that big captain
america easter egg
and now he's a member of the team
jumping around through time trying to
stop the other crownomicons the evil
people that are altering the time stream
one of the other targets was jim morita
who was a howling commando from captain
america's squad and first avenger
he's also the grandfather of
spider-man's principal at midtown high
here you can actually see his picture up
on the shelf here
there are a couple other big easter eggs
here that you probably recognize like
victoria hand was a character from
agents of shield earlier
conrad murphy is a secret warriors
easter egg that was a version of an
inhumans team that they did with daisy
in an earlier season of agents of shield
miss marvel herself will be the next
really big mcu
inhuman to show up but they haven't
quite explained the logic behind
inhumans in the mcu yet
even though we did have that inhumans tv
series i think they're just gonna
pretend like that never happened
so when they do introduce inhumans in
the mcu it'll be in a completely
different way and it'll probably have
something to do with the way they ended
things in avengers end game
all the snaps all the cosmic energy just
use your imagination it's free to
theorycraft right now
that series doesn't sound like it's
going to premiere till 2022 so it's
still a long ways off
michael phillips here is also a punisher
easter egg i know a lot of you are
wondering what's happening with punisher
in the mcu is john bernthal going to
come back and be the punisher in an mcu
project or a disney plus project like
moon knight or something a little bit
darker
as far as i know right now marvel
doesn't have any big plans for the
punisher character but he will come back
eventually he will show up in the mcu in
some new project
there's also a big infinity gauntlet
referenced during the episode too
something i cooked up that i call
the gauntlet so the big thing here is
they're just jumping through different
decades doing big marvel easter eggs
there's only going to be a couple more
episodes this season and that's
basically it
but there are rumors of them doing in
agents of sword
tv series as a sort of successor to
agents of shield or a spiritual
successor
it'd be a little bit different behind
the scenes because it'd be a disney plus
series and it'd be set on nick fury's
space station the sword space station
from the comics because the whole thing
with the mcu now is that they're sort of
transitioning away from big earth-based
stories for the most part in terms of
big avengers level stuff
and they're moving all that stuff into
outer space for more
cosmic stories so this just kind of
implies where the big villains are going
to be coming from during marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5.
the first time we'll really see that is
going to be during the marvel eternals
movie with the celestial host we'll see
them come to planet earth create the
eternals and then we get a bunch of big
cosmic mcu backstory
they did a little bit of that during the
guardians of the galaxy franchise
james gunn actually revealed the history
of that like how this scene came to be
why this wound up in the guardians of
the galaxy movie and not in some other
movie
he said it was all in service of setting
up the infinity saga payoffs during
infinity war in avengers end game so
they needed to do thanos
full on in the movie finally so they
just worked in
some thanos scenes and kind of
reimagined him cast josh brolin to
become their thanos in the mcu
then he said that kevin feige requested
that he actually do a brief
history of the marvel universe in the
infinity stones explain the infinity
stones
so that's why the collector has this big
scene explaining the infinity stones to
the guardians of the galaxy in the
origin of the universe
so even though shield is still going to
exist in marvel phase 4 for the most
part the mcu stories especially the
disney plus stuff
is transitioning to sword stories we're
gonna see them introduced for the first
time during the one division series
remember darcy from the thor movies
she's actually coming back during one
division two we don't know exactly what
she'll be doing but she'll also be one
of those agents of sword i'm also
assuming that jane foster is probably
working with sword
too at some point tom holland was
posting a bunch of stuff recently
they've just started filming so i'll do
a new spider-man and uncharted movie
video
sometime later today or tomorrow so look
out for that as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
that video when i post it
while you wait for everything click here
for my new venom 2 spider-man video
and click here for my new doctor strange
2 mcu
ghost rider video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay
safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you